are federal prisons supposed to be like
nicer than other ones
yeah yeah okay boom i was in i ended up
going to a camp
a federal camp i was in there with emery
emery jones okay yeah he was in the same
federal camp
and uh basically i remember i got to us
i got to i got to the atlanta usp
and uh i was talking to my bunkie he was
telling me about the atlanta camp he was
like yeah
yeah i was at the camp and you know what
i mean i went to the mall i left each
time i leave in the
prison and going to a mall and i'm like
i'm not even paying attention because
they don't even sound real so i'm
thinking like it's just
cat or whatever so i end up making it to
a spot a camp
and people are leaving the jail they got
a gate around it but it's like no
gun towers and it's got and it's like
the perimeter is next to a medium medium
security prison
and it's a camp a minimum security
prison you know i'm saying for people
who said who who's on their way home
right right that's what i'm saying uh
emery was there at the end of his bed
uh so yeah people delete a [ __ ]
that's what people do
and i left my baby mama came i left i
got some [ __ ]
i brought [ __ ] back into jail and
everything had a cell phone all type of
[ __ ]
jordan's henny everything so you could
have
well first of all [ __ ] brought
in a bazooka so at that point in time
they're not considering that [ __ ]
contraband or did you have it tucked
hell yeah they didn't know we had that
[ __ ] where do you hide a bottle of
hennessy
uh to be honest with honest with you we
held it
okay first it's a team of us right right
shout out my man sam man my man sway my
man
uh just those are dudes i was locked up
with
uh sam man he used to he used to be like
a porter
he said he used to like do the trash
yeah so he's like hide the [ __ ] under
the trash can he's the only
person who trusts who touched the trash
on the unit so he used to hide the [ __ ]
under the trash
under the trash lining yeah hell yeah so
what we did it was glass bottle though
so what the [ __ ] is glass doing on the
prison comments
right right right after we drink the
bottle here put the
glass in a pillow case break it up break
it up real fine
and dispose of it yeah
just crazy but damn that's crazy so you
got to leave get [ __ ] bring [ __ ] back
in
it was kind of like you know like i mean
that [ __ ]
sounds i should sound crazy now mind you
even though this is a camp this is still
prison it's still prison it's still a
[ __ ] prison so it's people in here
who
who who've been in here for 20 years who
never did know [ __ ] like that in 20
years
it was just [ __ ] like that in there
who just wanted this for me to tell the
story okay oh yo
young blood so you saw her i heard you
left yesterday
man how was it out there can i smell
your fingers
[Laughter]
real like these [ __ ] they can't
believe i was just out there like that
you know yeah back in here these [ __ ]
been down for 20 joints that's crazy hey
so you said you were locked up with
emory did you guys have a relationship
when you were locked up together
emery you know he was a do everybody
bother emery because they knew
it was like yo this i mean they knew
that was hoes man and we know when this
[ __ ] go home he was going to be
set up even though he came in he came
home and he worked for his and he became
for sure his
own man oh for sure i mean yo man like
like
you know obviously we don't really know
exactly what happened but he kind of you
know
he took that on the ch on the chin for
the big homie definitely definitely
uh you know i mean i really like mmm
live you know what i'm saying
but we knew of each other we knew who
each other was